[Music]  people will look back at this as the  exact moment that last bit of  Riverdale's innocence finally died  hopefully oh great you're shocked touch  [Music]  game how the bathroom enjoys this man  wearing this hood with a gun I'm popping  and then he pointed it at my dad bye  you're too many anyone for a moment it  looked like you were about to say  something about the hood guy and  reconsidered part of what makes you so  endearing is your utter lack of a public  face me and my dad were witnesses pop  gate - what if he gets back people have  grudges people have enemies I mean think  of where we live  fathers are killing their sons it's  entirely conceivable display hit just  mad its goals something else dark like  the Angel of Death of conquer it if  things are going to be different no  mommy better  you'll see  [Music]